look i know that disney is hyper aware
these days of what the internet's going
to freak out about baby yoda and
mandalorian
boom immediately broke the internet slow
pan up on captain america holding thor's
hammer and end game
nothing better evan peters as quick
silver and wand division
big boner energy that's a boner with an
h that's his real name don't hit us with
that one youtube that's not on us that's
a disney thing
they know the theories they know the
hashtags but most of all they know how
to manipulate the memes but for their
new series falcon and the winter soldier
i've got something they'd never think of
something that would be on a complete
other tier of iconic ladies and
gentlemen to you i present the meme
kick welcome punch
make him call it a falcon punch just
have him say it once just
once disney show me your moves
[Applause]
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show where our national colors are
red white and click bait green so let's
say for a minute that you're marvel
congratulations on your boatloads of
money but you also have yourself a
problem
in avengers 3 had your big bad throw a
literal moon
at people and it wasn't even his
finishing move in the last major film
you mixed together a decade's worth of
every character that has the potential
to sell an action figure you killed off
the guy that started it all
so how do you top all of that well if
the two disney plus installments that
kicked off this new phase are any
indication the strategy wasn't to go
wider
it was to go deeper sure one division on
the surface was a kooky offbeat riff on
sitcom tropes but underneath it was an
emotionally devastating exploration of
being trapped in your own personal
prison of grief trauma and loss
and now their newest installment the
falcon and the winter soldier seems to
be doing the exact same thing
what on the surface appeared to be a
rollicking buddy cop action movie with
two relatively overlooked faces from the
big team ups is in actuality a series
tackling
the issues that come along with a
superhero wearing a national flag as a
costume
you know like the fact that not everyone
on the planet sees that flag and
immediately thinks oh hey there's the
good guy
aren't the stars and stripes a little
old-fashioned ah nothing quite like a
disney plus series that covers all those
family-friendly topics like geopolitics
national identity the treatment of
military veterans
racism and what it actually means for a
superhero to also be a symbol of a
country
oh boy i'm gonna have to block so many
uncles on facebook now that new episodes
of this are coming out but
true to its sister from another mr
series one division you can bet that
this one is also gonna have its fair
share of twists and turns meaning it's
time for us to do what we did with wanda
and friends take a crack at breaking
apart everything that's gonna happen in
the show before
episode 2 hits the airwaves the
streaming waves it's all just the
internet these are all just glorified
internet videos we can agree with that
right they're on the same status as this
show
suck it disney but just because the
metaphorical bright shiny object this
time is politics doesn't mean that
marvel isn't gonna throw in some
diabolical twists and shocking reveals
and even though it's early in the series
there are definitely some clues out
there that made us think that we might
already have this one figured out or at
least we're gonna try
okay so the early setup for the falcon
and the winter soldier looks like this
sam wilson aka the falcon starts the
series off with an immediate twist
despite steve rogers passing on the
captain america mantle to him during the
conclusion of endgame sam decides yeah
you know what nah
hard pass instead he decides to gift the
shield to the smithsonian's captain
america exhibit we need
new heroes one suited for the times
we're in
hey i will have you know that chris
evans biceps are timeless
most ungrateful gift getter ever anyway
instead of donning the shield sam keeps
busy in two ways the first is helping
his sister with her financially strapped
business where he comes to realize that
there are some things that not even
superheroes can overcome
like the bank and that's kind of a joke
but also not really
things tighten up funny how things
always tighten around us
i'm on your side after all he's a hero
is there any chance and of course you
could say no that i could get a selfie
with your arms out are you serious
yeah turns out that saving the universe
doesn't pay all that well sam's
storyline is rife with undercurrents
about american racism economic hardship
and it's a clear allegory for the unique
difficulties faced by military veterans
trying to return to normal society i
guess we can rule out avengers 5
being called the subtlety war when he's
not battling lone officers the falcon's
other preoccupation is helping friends
in the us army seek answers about a new
group of troublemakers calling
themselves the flag smashers this new
group of villains wear black and red
masks and claim to believe in a world
without borders stating that things were
better during the blip
call themselves the flag smashers was
that a new thing bad guys give
themselves bad names basically they
think that
the world is better during the blip oh
also one of the flag smashers seems to
have super soldier strength but he's
wearing a mask like the rest of them so
we can't see who it is yet uh-oh who's
that reveal gonna be
it seems like the show wants us to
wonder if bucky is being bad again and
might not even know it himself but since
the internet didn't learn its lesson
from wand division people are
already sure it must be wolverine or
deadpool or daredevil
heck i wouldn't even be surprised if
there were still some mephisto hangers
on
mephisto mephistos i believe
mephisto is still coming and to make
everything just that much worse for sam
the first episode ends with the shocking
reveal that the government lied about
agreeing to retire the shield
instead they announced that they've
selected their own new captain america
and unlike the original this one is not
here to be a hero for everybody
while we love heroes who put their lives
on the line to defend earth
we also need a hero to defend this
country oh and uh bucky's here too
for reasons i guess honestly he can't
stop having nightmares that helpfully
advance the plot also his name's in the
title of the show
so obviously a lot is already going on
but even if it's not
your literal job to dig through kevin
feige's recycling bin for youtube
content you can probably see why some
people are going to be rage posting
about the show's debut episode
in one episode you've already introduced
bucky a disabled vet struggling with
ptsd
sam confronting injustice of all forms
while receiving the old thank you for
your service but not that much
one radical organization that's against
the idea of nations well the new captain
america is all about
murica first i mean i guess once your
main character is literally wearing a
country's flag as his uniform while he
runs around punching people whether you
intend to or not you're kind of telling
a story tinged with political messaging
in fact it's the whole reason the
franchise exists in the first place
marvel back before they were called
marvel put captain america punching out
hitler on the cover of their first issue
what's such a big deal about that well
this was before the u.s had actually
entered world war
ii at a point when much of the country
still didn't believe we should be
involved and prominent political voices
like the america first movement said
that we should leave those nazis
alone bad take but it was a popular take
at the time there's captain america
being like no
i'm a flag punching him in comic book
form but now it's time to talk theories
in much the same way that a lot of fans
who knew their marvel lore were able to
guess that wandavision's agnes wasn't
really who she said she was before the
show even started airing it'll come as
no surprise to learn that the smug
looking guy wearing the riot cop version
of a captain america suit will turn out
to be one of the big bads of the series
need proof well what falcon in the
winter soldier seems to be pulling
heaviest from is the works of the late
mark gruenwald gruenwald wrote the
captain america series for 10 years from
1985 to 1995
and was dedicated to using captain
america to explore real issues about
patriotism politics and american values
in a context that his mostly young
readers could respond to
gruenwald made it a point to create
villains that would be specific
to captain america as opposed to generic
foes as such his steve rogers battled a
mix of both super villains and
real world evils like bigotry militant
groups and political corruption
also steve was a werewolf for a while
they can't all be winners but
gruenwald's masterpiece was the 1987
captain america no more
or just the captain arc where steve
refuses to follow a government directive
he disagrees with and is officially
stripped of his title of captain america
he's replaced by his former rival a man
named
john walker and uh wouldn't you know it
but that just so happens to
also be the name of the replacement
captain in falcon in the winter soldier
hmm what do we know about this guy in
the comics
walker starts as the character super
patriot a hashtag
spawn version of captain america he's
arrogant he's a sellout he's just an
all-around not good guy
for instance to boost his fame he stages
a fight against a group of fake
extremist supporters of captain america
to make it clear that
he is america's true patriot gotta say
though for as obnoxious as he is he does
have this iconic line of ma'am if uncle
sam wanted me to be mickey mouse
i'd do it anyway the tldr of this guy is
that he embodies the idea of corrupt
patriotism patriotism taken to dangerous
extremes
often resorting to using extreme force
even killing people with his bare hands
he's eventually booted from the captain
america title and adopts the name u.s
agent but his use as a symbol is pretty
consistent across the franchise
he's the don't version of captain
america so seeing him put on camera just
looks more and more like marvel building
up to a bad guy
avengers team something that we've
talked about in a previous theory
walker as the anti-cap white vision as
the anti-vision evil black widow and
thaddeus ross from their new movie maybe
a return from agatha or
wanda herself and red hulk or
abomination because
every team needs their hull of course
that is talking a long ways out but the
pieces are definitely starting to come
together let's look a bit more short
term though because here's the thing if
there's a twist in the falcon in the
winter soldier it's probably not that
the new captain america is a bad dude
everyone can see that coming and it's
also not that zemo is going to show up
because you know he's in the commercials
so let's instead talk about the flag
smashers
in the comics flag smasher not an
extremist group but rather just one dude
was another mark gruenwald creation
he's pretty much supposed to be a super
villain anti-patriot who believes that
national allegiances no matter what they
are
are responsible for the world's evils as
such he tries to undermine
all world governments through his
network ultimatum which
i am not kidding was an acronym for get
this
underground liberated totally integrated
mobile army
to unite mankind yeah that is some heavy
aardvark
right there oh you don't know aardvark
aardvark that's my acronym yeah it
stands for awkward and ridiculous dumb
verbiage attaining real cringe you gotta
spell cringe with a k to make it work
also flag smasher had a mace
for smashing flags i don't know maces
just make everything cooler anyway it's
probably for the best that the flag
smasher group in the show
only seems to be taking the name and the
general ideology but you can immediately
see how the flag smashers make sense as
a villain for a series about who gets to
be the new captain america
they're against national symbols captain
america is
one of those national symbols cut and
dry
except there's one major problem with
this the mouse
think about it the mcu is all about
connecting everything to everything else
and not just in terms of continuity
between movies characters and streaming
shows this media empire is built on
people from different backgrounds
assembling how else could you have a
norse god of thunder and an i
shoot arrows good man team up connection
is good in this series
walls and isolationism is bad it's a
confluence of corporate creative synergy
so organically executed that you can
feel the ghost of walt disney himself
saluting from beneath the matterhorn or
his cryogenic freezing tube or wherever
they're preserving his body
being pro-global not only delivers a
progressive feel-good message
it comes with the added perk that the
whole globe now wants to buy your merch
in this way disney's interests seem to
agree with the ideology
if not the methods of the flag smashers
which begs the question
why would a studio set up a bunch of
characters who espouse pretty much a
punk rock version of not only their
entire franchise philosophy but also
their entire business model to be the
villains
of their series they wouldn't unless
they wanted to
look like that's what they were doing to
surprise the audience and deliver a
pointed message about what heroes are
meant to look like and as sam said
embody who they are today
and that my friends is why we're calling
it at least one of the big secrets
waiting to be unveiled in the falcon of
the winter soldier is that the flag
smashers are not the big bads that the
show wants us to think they are
after all in the comics even the
original flag smasher actually turned
against
ultimatum when he learned that some of
his then recent funding had been coming
from the red skull so in a similar vein
could it be that the flag smashers in
the show
mean well but are actually being misled
by a villain manipulating them from
behind the scenes
maybe someone like zemo who has shown in
civil war that that's exactly how he
likes to operate
as for what that means or how it
specifically plays out well that's
probably a bit too early to say
especially given that both bucky and
zemo being back raises the possibility
that we're dealing with mind control and
people being puppeteered into doing
evil's bidding or maybe more likely the
flag smashers don't exist
at all and the government just made up a
false flag threat so john walker's
captain america could have an arch enemy
right away my money's actually on that
one that the flag smashers are actually
an inside job i don't have a lot of
proof to point out for that one but i
like the narrative angle and it's very
reminiscent of the walker origin story
that i mentioned before where he attacks
a fake group of extremists supporting
captain america to achieve
national headlines and buy in for
himself or
and this one is admittedly the long shot
what if there was a recurring captain
america franchise character who was
almost
always absent for long unexplained
periods of time but
also always happens to show up exactly
where they need
to direct steve or his allies in
directions that move the story in
necessary ways someone whose backstory
is oddly piecemeal and whose
interactions with steve were always a
little bit uncomfortable in context
someone who is scheduled to show up as a
part of this series as well
what if that character sharon carter has
been a villain
this whole time all right probably not
but hey did you know that red skull has
himself a daughter maybe she inherits
the family business
just saying they're all just theories
film
theories and cuts
you